This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The United States and Canada share the longest international border in the world. And ever since Canada got the keys to the place in 1867, we've been pretty peaceful and genial neighbors to each other. The previous landlord, Great Britain, will the US had a bit more of a spotting relationship with them. We invaded them, they burned out our house, it was a whole thing. But even though the border with Canada is now pretty tame, when two countries touch each other over a stretch of 5,500 miles, it can result in some surprisingly weird disputes, misunderstandings, geographical quirks, and some really good stories.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美国和加拿大共享着世界上最长的国际边界。自1867年加拿大获得这片土地的管辖权以来，我们一直是彼此非常和平且友好的邻居。至于前任房东英国，美国与他们的关系就有点复杂了。我们入侵过他们，他们烧毁了我们的房子，那真是一场大戏。但尽管现在与加拿大的边界相当平静，当两个国家在长达5500英里的地带接壤时，仍可能导致一些令人惊讶的奇怪纠纷、误解、地理怪癖以及一些非常精彩的故事。
And we have a few of them for you today. Here to tell us the first one is producer Vivian Leibh. Hey, Viv. Hey, Roman. So what do you have for us? Okay. So the border between the US and Canada is a very special, very weird place. But there was a legal case from the early 2000s that showed this really odd problem with the boundary in the West between Canada and Washington state specifically.
今天我们为大家准备了几个这样的故事。首先由制片人薇薇安·莱布为我们讲述。嘿，薇薇。嘿，罗曼。你给我们带来了什么？好的。美国和加拿大之间的边界是一个非常特殊、非常奇怪的地方。但21世纪初发生的一起法律案件，揭示了加拿大与华盛顿州之间西部边界的一个非常奇怪的问题。
This is the first time I'd ever heard of this problem. This is Richard Sanders. He was a Washington State Supreme Court Justice from 1995 to 2011. And just to Sanders has also been practicing law for over 50 years. Old lawyers never died. They just lose their appeal, right? So I wanted to talk to him about this case that made it all the way up to the state Supreme Court in 2001 called State versus Norman. Well, when I first read the facts of the case, I thought it was some sort of a joke, and I laughed my head off.
这是我第一次听说这个问题。这位是理查德·桑德斯。他曾于1995年至2011年担任华盛顿州最高法院法官。桑德斯从事法律工作也超过了50年。老律师永远不会死，他们只是失去了上诉权，对吧？所以我很想和他聊聊这起在2001年一直打到州最高法院的案件，名为“州诉诺曼案”。嗯，当我第一次读到案情时，我以为这是个笑话，笑得我前仰后合。
But of course, it's a serious matter. Oh, this is exciting. So what are the facts of the case? So in 1996, three people named Helen Norman, Kevin Beelin, and Laura Lee Strattwick were apprehended by US customs officials, and then searched at the border crossing between Washington and British Columbia, Canada.
但当然，这是一个严肃的问题。哦，这太令人兴奋了。那么案情是什么呢？1996年，三个人——海伦·诺曼、凯文·比林和劳拉·李·斯特拉特威克——被美国海关官员逮捕，并在华盛顿州与加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省之间的边境口岸进行了搜查。
They were found to be in the possession of drugs, and one of the three also was found to be in the possession of a stolen credit card. So all three were arrested, charged, and then tried. But their particular defense didn't deny that they were in possession of drugs or stolen property. What they argued was that at the time of their arrest, they were actually outside of the jurisdiction of Washington State, and therefore could not be tried in Washington
他们被发现持有毒品，其中一人还被发现持有一张被盗信用卡。于是这三人全部被捕、被起诉并接受审判。但他们的辩护理由并不是否认持有毒品或赃物。他们辩称，在被捕时，他们实际上处于华盛顿州的司法管辖区之外，因此不能在华盛顿州受审。
Court. Huh. What were they arguing that they were just in the jurisdiction of, you know, British Columbia, Canada? No. They claimed that they were neither in the jurisdiction of British Columbia, Canada. No, they claimed that they were neither in Canada nor Washington. Their defense said that they were actually in a strip of land that existed between Washington and Canada. I didn't know such a strip of land existed. I thought they were right up against each other.
哈。他们是辩称自己处于，你知道，加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省的管辖区内吗？不。他们声称自己既不在加拿大，也不在华盛顿。他们的辩护律师说，他们实际上是在华盛顿和加拿大之间存在的一条狭长地带。我不知道还有这样的狭长地带。我以为它们是紧挨在一起的。
Whether or not Washington and Canada's touch was actually something that was up for debate. This case raises basic yet simple jurisdictional questions of what and where. What is in the northern border of our state? Where in relation to that border, do these crimes take place? So the three defendants were searched south of the International Canadian border. That is a fact. But the space basically comes down to where the Washington State border actually is. So in the early to mid 1800s, the US and Great Britain jointly occupy the territory, North of California, and west of the Rocky Mountains, also known as the Pacific Northwest. But during this time, there was this frankly problematic idea that it was America's God-given right to take this Westford territory.
华盛顿和加拿大是否真的接壤，这本身就是一个值得争论的问题。这个案件提出了关于“什么”和“哪里”的基本而简单的司法管辖权问题。我们州的北部边界是什么？这些犯罪行为相对于该边界发生在什么位置？所以这三名被告是在国际加拿大边界以南被搜查的。这是一个事实。但空间问题归根结底在于华盛顿州边界到底在哪里。在19世纪初到中期，美国和英国共同占领了加利福尼亚以北、落基山脉以西的领土，也就是所谓的太平洋西北地区。但在那段时间里，有一种坦率地说很有问题的想法，即夺取这片西部领土是美国天赐的权利。
So Roman, you've heard of the phrase 54 or 40 or fight? I have, yeah, it's catchy. Yeah, so just as a little recap, President James K. Polk's big campaign issue in 1844 was to continue the expansion of the United States to include Texas, which was then Mexico, and the Pacific Northwest. So 54, 40 or fight became sort of his battle cry. And the numbers referred to the Northern boundary of the Oregon territory at the latitude line of 54 degrees, 40 minutes. Right. And so up to that point, we will fight for whatever days up to 54 degrees in 40 minutes. Yes, although the Polk administration actually did not end up getting 54. So the Oregon Treaty of 1846 was signed between the US and Great Britain, and it
所以罗曼，你听说过“54-40或开战”这个短语吗？听过，是的，很顺口。是的，简单回顾一下，詹姆斯·K·波尔克总统在1844年的竞选核心议题是继续扩张美国，将当时属于墨西哥的德克萨斯和太平洋西北地区纳入版图。所以“54-40或开战”成了他的战斗口号。这些数字指的是俄勒冈领土的北部边界，即北纬54度40分。没错。所以在那之前，我们会为直到54度40分的所有土地而战。是的，尽管波尔克政府最终并没有得到54度40分。所以1846年美国和英国签署了《俄勒冈条约》，它
established that the boundary between the two territories would be set at the 49th parallel west of the Rocky Mountains, so they I guess kind of settled for 49-40 or fight, so the boundary was established, surveyed and marked. And then four decades later in 1889, Washington was formally incorporated into the Union as a state. And the drafters of the state constitution just adopted that international border and decided to use that same language found in the Oregon
确定了两国领土之间的边界将设在落基山脉以西的北纬49度线，所以我想他们算是接受了“49-40或开战”，于是边界被确定、测量并标记了出来。四十年后的1889年，华盛顿州正式并入联邦成为一个州。州宪法的起草者直接采用了那条国际边界，并决定使用《俄勒冈条约》中相同的措辞，即华盛顿的北部边界是“沿北纬49度线向西”。好吧，到目前为止这一切都说得通。那么，问题来了。他们把北纬49度线标错了。他们是怎么做到这一点的？好吧，我得跳过这一部分，因为你肯定不想让我给你解释土地测量的天文方法。但第一个出错的地方是，他们用来测量土地的仪器受到了该地区局部地球引力的偏移。
treaty that the Northern boundary of Washington was, quote, west along the 49th parallel. OK, all this makes sense so far. So OK, so here's the rub. They marked the 49th parallel. Okay, all this makes sense so far. So okay, so here's the rub. They marked the 49th parallel wrong. What do they manage to do that? Okay, so I'm gonna have to kind of yada yada this point because you do not want me explaining astronomical methods of land surveying to you. But the first thing that went wrong was that the instrument that they used to survey the land was offset by the local gravitational pull of the earth in that
（注：此处原文重复，已合并）
specific area. And the second thing that went wrong was that when the surveyors marked the 49th parallel, they basically marked two latitude points and then traced a straight line in between them and said, bam, there's the 49th parallel. Well, the earth is famously round. It's known for its roundness. Yeah, exactly. So the straight line indicating the 49th parallel was actually off by several hundred feet in some places because it should have been a curved line to account for the curvature of the earth. Okay, so certain areas, the boundary between Washington, Canada is in the wrong place, but
第二个出错的地方是，当测量员标记北纬49度线时，他们基本上标记了两个纬度点，然后在它们之间画了一条直线，说：“砰，这就是北纬49度线。”嗯，地球众所周知是圆的。它以圆润著称。是的，完全正确。所以，指示北纬49度线的直线在某些地方实际上偏离了几百英尺，因为它应该是一条考虑到地球曲率的曲线。好吧，所以某些区域，华盛顿和加拿大之间的边界位置不对，但是
I kind of don't understand why it matters because that just means that the border between the United States and Canada just, you know, shifted a little bit. So what does it really matter? Yes. Okay. So in 1809, there was another treaty between the United States and Great Britain that actually addressed how messed up the border between the US and Canada was. So, basically, the two countries agreed to like, gussie up the US Canada boundary with more
我不太明白这为什么重要，因为那只是意味着美国和加拿大之间的边界稍微移动了一点。那到底有什么关系呢？是的。好吧。1809年，美国和英国之间签署了另一项条约，实际上解决了美加边界混乱的问题。所以，基本上，两国同意用更现代的测量技术来修整美加边界。
modern surveying techniques. And then moved some stuff over and then decided that the international border was where it was landmarked. So that precise language of 49th parallel was actually dropped from the international border. But the state of Washington did not update its constitution with this language. So the Washington State border is actually in some places several hundred feet below the international border, which is where we come back to that 2001 Supreme Court case, state versus Norman, where Justice Standards was on the court.
然后移动了一些东西，并决定国际边界就在地标所在的地方。因此，“北纬49度线”这一精确措辞实际上从国际边界定义中删除了。但华盛顿州并没有在其宪法中更新这一措辞。所以华盛顿州的边界在某些地方实际上比国际边界低了几百英尺，这就是我们回到2001年最高法院案件“州诉诺曼案”的原因，当时桑德斯法官就在法庭上。
Their defense was that the state of Washington had no jurisdiction because they were outside the state when the crime was committed. So the three defendants in this case were clearly within the boundary that was demarcated as Washington State, but after there are rest their defense use GPS to locate the customs facility where they were searched and technically it took place north of Washington State jurisdiction. Yeah, it's a technicality, but the law is made of technicalities, and our jurisdiction of our state boards is circumscribed by the borders of the state. So if you're on the high seas, or if you're an Idaho, or Oregon, or in Canada, you cannot be prosecuted into the laws of the state of Washington.
他们的辩护是，华盛顿州没有管辖权，因为他们在犯罪时身处州外。所以本案的三名被告显然在划定的华盛顿州边界内，但在被捕后，他们的辩护律师使用GPS定位了他们被搜查的海关设施，从技术上讲，它发生在华盛顿州管辖范围以北。是的，这是一个技术细节，但法律就是由技术细节构成的，我们州边界的管辖权是由州边界所限定的。所以如果你在公海，或者在爱达荷州、俄勒冈州或加拿大，你就不能被华盛顿州的法律起诉。
So it is a technicality, but it's pretty fundamental technicality. But what I find fascinating is that if these three defendants were able to get the state supreme court to side with their case, it would essentially acknowledge that the Washington State border is not where it says it is. And it would formally establish like a strip
所以这是一个技术细节，但这是一个非常根本的技术细节。但我发现迷人的是，如果这三名被告能够让州最高法院支持他们的案件，那本质上就承认了华盛顿州的边界并不在它所说的地方。并且它将正式确立一条位于华盛顿和加拿大之间，但仍属于美国领土的、数百英尺宽的狭长地带。嗯。那么法院在这个案件中作出了什么裁决？你知道，不出所料，州最高法院裁定，不，并不存在这种既不属于华盛顿也不属于加拿大，
of land hundreds of feet wide that is between Washington and Canada, but still part of the US. Hmm. So what did the court decide in this case? You know, unsurprisingly, the state Supreme Court determined that no, there is not this nebulous strip of territory that doesn't belong to Washington or Canada,
且不受州管辖的模糊领土。这说得通。我的意思是，这些问题在法庭案件中经常出现，归根结底，法官只会说：“不，显然那不是本意。”如果常识规定人们必须遵守法律，那么他们就必须遵守这些法律。
and it's just like free of state jurisdiction. That makes sense. I mean, these come up a fair amount, you know, like in court cases, and really what it comes down to is a judge just goes, no, clearly that wasn't what was meant. And if common sense dictates that people are subjected to the laws, then they will be subjected to those laws.
（注：此处原文重复，已合并）
Yes, that is true. What I did find interesting about this case is that, you know, the justices cited eight to one that the Washington State Boarder is where it's always been because common sense. But there was one dissenting judge, and I will give you two guesses as to who that loan dissenting Supreme Court justice was. Wait, so this is our guide, Justice Sanders, that you've been talking to? It was indeed. I thought it deserved at least one vote
是的，那是真的。我发现这个案件有趣的地方在于，你知道，法官们以八比一的投票结果裁定华盛顿州边界就在它一直所在的地方，因为常识。但有一位持异议的法官，我给你两次机会猜猜那位唯一的异议最高法院法官是谁。等等，这就是你一直在谈论的我们的向导，桑德斯法官吗？确实是他。我以为它至少应该在最高法院获得一票，而他们确实得到了。所以这就像是对这种模糊性需要非一致性裁决的事实的一种声明。是的，他就像是，“干得好，干得好，能拿到一票。”但是，你知道，尽管这个裁决本可以创造这种司法困境，但桑德斯法官最终写下了这份尖刻的异议书，我认为这可能是最有趣的最高法院意见书之一。
on the Supreme Court and that's what they got. So it was just like, it was like a statement of the fact that that ambiguity requires a non-unanimous decision. Yeah, he's like, well played, well played to get one vote. But like, you know, even though this decision could have created like this jurisdictional limbo, you know, Justice Sanders ended up writing this scathing descent that I think is probably one of the most entertaining, you know, Supreme Court opinions.
（注：此处原文重复，已合并）
Like he says that the state constitution is unambiguous. And if her part is of NICIA could figure out astronomical measurements of latitude in the second century BC, then these surveyors 2000 years later probably had the means to locate the 49th parallel. I mean, I get that he wants to honor the constitution, but maybe the limitations of, you know, 19th century surveys should be taken into account and you can't just redraw things. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I honestly don't know if I could locate the 49th parallel if I looked at a map, so I can't really blame them. But it was a pretty creative event regardless. Oh, totally, yeah. Well, it's nice to know that people are actually reading the state constitutions.
他说州宪法是明确的。如果公元前二世纪的尼西亚人都能算出纬度的天文测量值，那么两千年后的这些测量员可能也有能力定位北纬49度线。我的意思是，我明白他想尊重宪法，但也许应该考虑到19世纪测量的局限性，你不能就这样重新绘制边界。是的，是的。我的意思是，老实说，如果我看地图，我不知道自己能不能找到北纬49度线，所以我真的不能责怪他们。但无论如何，这都是一个非常有创意的辩护。哦，完全是。好吧，很高兴知道人们真的在阅读州宪法。
Like, you know, it's just trying to get out of a drug offense. Thanks for the story, Vicki. Thank you. So I'm here with Kurt Cole, said the digital director and co-author of the 9-9% of visible city, Hey, Kurt. Hey, Roman. And you have a Canadian border story for us? Oh, I do. Okay, hit me.
就像，你知道，这只是为了摆脱毒品指控。谢谢你的故事，薇薇。谢谢。我现在在演播室里和库尔特·科尔在一起，他是《99%隐形城市》的数字总监和合著者。嘿，库尔特。嘿，罗曼。你有一个关于加拿大边境的故事要告诉我们吗？哦，我有。好的，说吧。
It's about this pair of adjacent parks that are along the US Canadian border in Blaine, Washington and Surrey, British Columbia. Okay, so we're still on the west side of the continent. Yeah. And in these parks, like right where they meet along the border, there's this big piece arch monument with this inscription, may these gates never be closed. this inscription, may these gates never be closed. Wow, well, that's a pretty bold statement for a border, right? Which is like, antithetical to what borders are usually about. So what's the story there?
这是关于沿着华盛顿州布莱恩市和不列颠哥伦比亚省萨里市的美加边境的一对相邻公园的故事。好的，所以我们还在大陆的西侧。是的。在这些公园里，就在它们沿着边界交汇的地方，有一个巨大的和平拱门纪念碑，上面刻着：“愿这些大门永不关闭。”哇，对于一个边境来说，这真是一个非常大胆的声明，对吧？这与边境通常的意义背道而驰。那么那里的故事是什么呢？
Well, the arch and the parks date back to the early 1900s, but that never closed sentiment is actually a nod to the War of 1812 between the US and the UK. And at the end of that conflict, basically both sides signed a treaty to leave the border between the US and Canada, undefended as a sign of friendship. And so now there's this arch with this sentiment written on it, but can you truly walk through it whenever you want? Well, yeah, for most of the past century, you absolutely could. And with this park spaces open for visitors, people can just freely cross into it from either
嗯，拱门和公园的历史可以追溯到20世纪初，但那种“永不关闭”的情绪实际上是对美国和英国之间1812年战争的一种致敬。在那场冲突结束时，双方基本上签署了一项条约，将美加边界保持为非武装状态，作为友谊的象征。所以现在有一个刻着这种情感的拱门，但你真的可以随时穿过它吗？嗯，是的，在过去一个世纪的大部分时间里，你绝对可以。随着这些公园空间向游客开放，人们可以从任何
side and then hang out without actually waiting to get through some tedious border checkpoint. So it ends up being this kind of no-man's land. And then when they leave, visitors just have to exit back to their country of origin. Okay. then when they leave, visitors just have to exit back to their country of origin. Okay, so the arch doesn't really operate as a checkpoint, but it sounds as if the entrance to each park might operate as checkpoint a little bit. Well, sort of, it's like you can freely walk into the park. Okay. And there's people patrolling the park, but the real keys you should have identification with you
一边自由地进入，然后在里面闲逛，而无需等待通过繁琐的边境检查站。所以它最终变成了一种“无人区”。当他们离开时，游客只需回到他们的原籍国即可。好的，所以拱门并没有真正作为检查站运作，但听起来每个公园的入口可能有点像检查站。嗯，算是吧，就像你可以自由地走进公园。好的。而且有人在公园里巡逻，但真正的关键是你应该随身携带身份证件，
because when you try to exit the park, like they wanna make sure that you're coming back into the country you're supposed to be coming back into. Yeah, okay, that makes sense, that makes sense. But it's a little less rigorous than what we think of as a normal international border checkpoint. Oh, absolutely, yeah, yeah. But it started to change a little bit
因为当你试图离开公园时，他们想确保你回到了你应该回到的那个国家。是的，好的，这说得通，这说得通。但这比我们认为的正常国际边境检查站要宽松一些。哦，绝对是，是的，是的。但它开始发生了一些变化，
in this past year and a half, you might imagine because of the pandemic. Right. Yeah, so each country maintains the controls inside of the park, right? And early in the pandemic, both sides kept everything open. But even after Canada decided to close its side down, Canadians have still been able to meet up with Americans by crossing into the US part along this one side.
在过去的一年半里，你可能想象得到，因为疫情。对。是的，所以每个国家都在公园内维持控制，对吧？在疫情初期，双方都保持一切开放。但即使在加拿大决定关闭其一侧后，加拿大人仍然能够通过穿过这一侧进入美国部分与美国人会面。
Well, I can imagine a lot of people are taking advantage of that because everything else was pretty closed. Oh, yeah, absolutely. Like a lot of friends and families split by the border have continued to gather here and there have even been a ton of by national weddings at the park. Well, that makes sense. I mean, it's a convenient way to get together and people like get married in parks.
嗯，我可以想象很多人都在利用这一点，因为其他地方都相当封闭。哦，是的，绝对是。很多被边境隔开的朋友和家人继续在这里聚会，公园里甚至还举办了大量的双国婚礼。嗯，这说得通。我的意思是，这是一种方便的聚会方式，而且人们喜欢在公园里结婚。
Yeah, absolutely. I don't know what you do after the ceremony. You just split a part again. Yeah, you go your separate ways. I mean, that's the crazy thing, right? It's like you still have to kind of go back to your country of origin. But it's still a pretty convenient place
是的，绝对是。我不知道仪式结束后你会做什么。你们只是再次分开。是的，你们各奔东西。我的意思是，这很疯狂，对吧？就像你仍然必须回到你的原籍国一样。但这仍然是一个非常方便的地方，
for people to get together and tell them right. Yeah, it's partly that direct ease of access, but also people fully crossing over in conventional ways have faced up to a two-week quarantine and COVID testing, but they can get around all that by meeting up in this spot instead. And as you might imagine, you know, divided families who can't afford to take all that time off of work to solve ice-late after a trip. I mean, this border zone loophole has been a real boon for that. I'm pretty careful about all the COVID stuff and I think that these quarantines are really, really effective and I'm just kind of surprised that both countries just haven't shut this down entirely. Yeah, and you know, that's kind of the craziest part, because legally, no matter what either country wants to do, neither side can fully close the border,
供人们聚会。是的，这部分是因为直接的便利性，但也因为以传统方式完全过境的人面临长达两周的隔离和新冠检测，但他们可以通过在这个地方会面来绕过所有这些。正如你可能想象的那样，你知道，无法负担所有这些休假时间来在旅行后进行自我隔离的离散家庭。我的意思是，这个边境区域的漏洞对他们来说是一个真正的福音。我对所有新冠相关的事情都非常小心，我认为这些隔离措施真的非常有效，我只是有点惊讶两国竟然没有完全关闭这个地方。是的，你知道，这才是最疯狂的部分，因为在法律上，无论任何一个国家想做什么，双方都不能完全关闭边境，
because that would be an international treaty violation. So this is the treaty that you mentioned dating back to the War of 1812. I mean, that thing really has teeth, like they have to keep the border open in some place. Yep, that's the idea. And so you still have authorities policing the parks and regulating who is allowed in and where they exit, but they're not really able to just stop people
因为那将违反国际条约。所以这就是你提到的可以追溯到1812年战争的条约。我的意思是，那东西真的很有约束力，他们必须在某个地方保持边境开放。是的，就是这个意思。所以你仍然有当局在公园里巡逻，并监管谁被允许进入以及他们在哪里离开，但他们真的无法阻止人们
from meeting up entirely. Huh, that's kind of amazing. So for the sake of argument, like what would happen if, you know, one side actually decided to like, put up a wall and shut the border down? I mean, Canada was pretty proactive when it came to COVID protocols and shutting the border down. Like, what would happen if they put their wall up? Well, that's the thing. I was looking into this and I found this immigration lawyer who was
完全会面。哈，这太神奇了。那么为了辩论起见，如果，你知道，一方真的决定，比如，建一堵墙并关闭边境会发生什么？我的意思是，加拿大在新冠协议和关闭边境方面非常主动。如果他们建起墙会发生什么？嗯，这就是问题所在。我调查过这件事，我找到了一个移民律师，他
interviewed by the CDC. And he says that a full closure would have some pretty wild side effects. And they would depend upon like which side Violates the agreement. Okay. So he claims that Canada broke the treaty in theory the US could lay claim to parts of Ontario and Quebec And if America broke it Canada could get parts of Maine, Michigan and Wisconsin So basically North American geography, as we do it, is contingent on this early 1800s treaty remaining in effect. That's just wild.
接受了CDC的采访。他说完全关闭会产生一些非常疯狂的副作用。而且它们取决于哪一方违反了协议。好的。所以他声称如果加拿大违反了条约，理论上美国可以对安大略省和魁北克省的部分地区提出主张。如果美国违反了条约，加拿大可以获得缅因州、密歇根州和威斯康星州的部分地区。所以基本上，我们所知的北美地理取决于这个19世纪初的条约是否继续有效。这太疯狂了。
But are people still kind of worried about meetups in this park during the pandemic anyway? Yeah, no, they do take it really seriously. And there are locals on both sides who are concerned about COVID from all these visitors, of course, which makes sense. And so a lot comes on to individual visitors. And some of them play it really safe, right? They just sit on their side of the border in chairs and chat with like people from the other side across the border. But, you know, whatever we think
但人们在疫情期间仍然担心在这个公园里会面吗？是的，不，他们确实非常认真地对待它。当然，双方都有当地人担心这些游客带来的新冠病毒，这说得通。所以很多事情取决于个人游客。他们中的一些人非常谨慎，对吧？他们只是坐在边境各自的一侧，坐在椅子上，和边境另一边的人聊天。但是，你知道，无论我们怎么想，
or the government thinks about it in terms of health and safety, it just kind of is what it is. Neither side can actually shut it down entirely. At least without you know, trading parts of Ontario and Maine in the process. Right. Except for that.
或者政府怎么看待健康和安全问题，它就是这样。双方都无法真正完全关闭它。至少在不交易安大略省和缅因州部分地区的情况下是这样。对。除了那个。
Yeah, exactly. Well, I'm so intrigued to this place exists. So thank you so much for telling me the story. I had no idea. Yeah, exactly. Well, I'm so intrigued that this place exists. So thank you so much for telling me the story. I had no idea. Yeah, at any time. So I'm talking in the studio today with Lasha Madon, who's one of the producers of this show. Lasha, I hear you have a story about a disputed island.
是的，完全正确。好吧，我对这个地方的存在非常着迷。所以非常感谢你告诉我这个故事。我完全不知道。是的，随时。所以今天我在演播室里和拉莎·马登交谈，她是这个节目的制片人之一。拉莎，我听说你有一个关于争议岛屿的故事。
Well, yes, but, Roman, I'm going to start this story by telling you a little bit of lore. Fantastic. I love lore. All right. It's a tale about a guy named Barnabas, but most people called him Tall Barney. Supposedly, he was six feet, seven and a half inches tall. Whoa. Tall Barney was born in Jones Port, Maine in 1835.
嗯，是的，但是，罗曼，我要从告诉你一点传说开始这个故事。太棒了。我喜欢传说。好的。这是一个关于一个叫巴纳巴斯的人的故事，但大多数人叫他“高个子巴尼”。据推测，他身高六英尺七英寸半。哇。高个子巴尼于1835年出生在缅因州的琼斯波特。
He was, by almost every written account, a crusty sea captain. There's a 2001 news article that described him as a, quote, reserved weathered sea salt of a man. Another called him a walking hurricane. Talbarni was rugged and strong, and he was just a bad temper. Some people claim that one time he punched a horse and killed it just from the punch. That does sound like lore, but I'll go with it.
几乎所有的书面记录都称他为一位脾气暴躁的船长。有一篇2001年的新闻文章形容他是一个“沉默寡言、饱经风霜的硬汉”。另一篇称他为“行走的飓风”。高个子巴尼坚韧强壮，而且脾气很坏。有些人声称有一次他一拳打死了一匹马。这听起来确实像传说，但我会接受它。
And so the tale goes like this. It's the spring of 1865 and in an attempt to avoid the Civil War, Tal Barney went out to sea. He camped out on this little island, 10 miles off the coast of Maine, called Machia's Seal Island. In overtime, Tall Barney came to believe that this island belonged to him. He put the island in his will. It was to go to the first male descendant to be named Barnabas, after him. So not just the first male descendant, but the first one named Barnabas. Right.
故事是这样的。那是1865年的春天，为了躲避内战，高个子巴尼出海了。他在这座距离缅因州海岸10英里的名为“马基亚斯海豹岛”的小岛上露营。随着时间的推移，高个子巴尼开始相信这座岛属于他。他把这座岛写进了遗嘱。它将传给第一个以他的名字命名的男性后裔，巴纳巴斯。所以不仅仅是第一个男性后裔，而是第一个叫巴纳巴斯的人。对。
That's so specific. And that took a couple generations, but his great grandson, Barna Norton, was born in 1915. And Barna then, for his entire life, claimed the island was his. For the next six decades, Machaya's Seal Island became the center of Barna Norton's world. He traveled to the island by boat thousands of times, taking bird lovers from around the world to tour it. Turns out the island is actually one of the world's best places to see puffins nesting, thousands of them. And for many, many years, Bna would tell the people on his boat a particular story.
这太具体了。这花了几代人的时间，但他的曾孙巴纳·诺顿出生于1915年。巴纳在他的一生中都声称这座岛是他的。在接下来的六十年里，马基亚斯海豹岛成了巴纳·诺顿世界的中心。他乘船数千次前往该岛，带着来自世界各地的爱鸟人士参观。事实证明，该岛实际上是世界上观赏海鹦筑巢的最佳地点之一，有成千上万只。多年来，巴纳会给船上的人讲一个特别的故事。
He would say, I own the island. It was given to me. So does he actually own it? Well, no. Okay. Good. The thing is, Barna's story conflicts with the official stances of both Canada and the US.
他会说：“我拥有这座岛。它是给我的。”那么他真的拥有它吗？嗯，没有。好的。很好。问题是，巴纳的故事与加拿大和美国的官方立场相冲突。
So the US-Canada border is the longest bilateral border between two countries in the world, right? It's 5,525 miles long. And this little chunk of 20 acres are the last crumbs of land that both countries claim as theirs. Meaning the dispute over this island is actually the last land border dispute between the US and Canada. It's been going on for centuries and it shows just how messy borders can be. It's a great example of how random and arbitrary borders are. People treat them like they were handed down from God and that they're immutable, but in fact they're very human creations.
所以美加边界是世界上两国之间最长的双边边界，对吧？它长5525英里。而这20英亩的小块土地是两国都声称属于自己的最后一点土地。这意味着对该岛的争端实际上是美加之间最后的陆地边界争端。它已经持续了几个世纪，这表明边界可能有多么混乱。这是一个关于边界是多么随机和武断的绝佳例子。人们对待它们就像它们是上帝传下来的，而且是不可改变的，但事实上它们是非常人为的创造。
So this is Stephen Kelly. He's a research scholar at the Sanford School of Public Policy at Duke. And before that, Stephen used to work in the Foreign Service. So he's spent a lot of time thinking about borders. Stephen's fascinated by Machia's Seal Island and what it represents. But he says the island itself, it's just a tiny hunk of rock, a treeless lump. A giant seal island is very unimpressive. And as you approach it, it's completely flat.
这位是斯蒂芬·凯利。他是杜克大学桑福德公共政策学院的研究学者。在此之前，斯蒂芬曾在外交部门工作。所以他花了很多时间思考边界问题。斯蒂芬对马基亚斯海豹岛及其代表的意义很着迷。但他说，岛本身只是一块小岩石，一个没有树的土块。巨大的海豹岛非常平庸。当你接近它时，它是完全平坦的。
And you can see a little bit of the lighthouse as you get closer and closer. But there are no trees, it's featureless. Machia seal island is about 10 miles off the coast of Maine. And it sits at the point where the Gulf of Maine meets the Bay of Fundy. Roman, I just sent you a link of what it looks like on a map if you want to take a look. Oh, it's small. It's like, you don't even, you don't even see the land.
当你越来越近时，你可以看到一点灯塔。但没有树，它毫无特色。马基亚斯海豹岛距离缅因州海岸约10英里。它位于缅因湾与芬迪湾交汇处。罗曼，如果你想看的话，我刚给你发了一个它在地图上看起来是什么样子的链接。哦，它很小。就像，你甚至，你甚至看不到陆地。
You just see like the little pointy arrow thingy. Until you get real close. And I mean, it's so small that no human has ever permanently inhabited the island, just just birds, a lot of birds. In fact, only 30 people are allowed per day to visit the island to see these birds during the summer months, 15 people from Canada, 15 from the US. Steven's been lucky enough to visit twice. And when you land, you have to walk on these wooden boardwalks that keep you from stepping
你只能看到像小尖箭头一样的东西。直到你真正靠近。我的意思是，它太小了，以至于从来没有人永久居住在这个岛上，只有鸟，很多鸟。事实上，夏季期间每天只允许30人上岛观鸟，15人来自加拿大，15人来自美国。斯蒂芬很幸运地去过两次。当你登陆时，你必须走在这些木板路上，防止你踩到
on and crushing eggs or hatchlings of the puffins and the razor-bills and the turns and the other birds that nest on the island. So as you're walking on these boardwalks, the turns can get very possessive about their nest, and they buzz you. They come down and actually hit your head. And they encourage you to carry an umbrella or a stick over your head to sort of ward them off or hope that they'll hit the stick rather than your head. I didn't realize there would be that much activity going on that that the birds have really taken over like it isn't the Barnabas is of the world who really own that island it's the birds
并压碎在岛上筑巢的海鹦、刀嘴海雀、燕鸥和其他鸟类的蛋或幼鸟。所以当你走在这些木板路上时，燕鸥会对它们的巢穴非常有占有欲，它们会嗡嗡地飞向你。它们会俯冲下来，真的撞到你的头。他们鼓励你带一把伞或一根棍子在头上，以驱赶它们，或者希望它们会撞到棍子而不是你的头。我没想到会有那么多活动，以至于鸟类真的接管了那个岛，真正拥有那个岛的不是世界上的巴纳巴斯们，而是鸟类。
on that island it's totally the birds so so how did this dispute over a rather you kind of like you know economically useless piece of land come about yeah so it's been a hard dispute for the two countries to settle because both sides are actually basing their arguments and historical documents that do help prove each point. So a quick history lesson, you ready? Oh, totally. Let's go. Okay. In 1783, the Treaty of Paris officially ended the Revolutionary War between Great Britain
在那个岛上，完全是鸟类。那么，关于这样一块在经济上毫无用处的土地的争端是怎么产生的呢？是的，这对两国来说是一个很难解决的争端，因为双方实际上都基于有助于证明各自观点的历史文件。所以，快速的历史课，准备好了吗？哦，完全准备好了。开始吧。好的。1783年，《巴黎条约》正式结束了英国与美国殖民地之间的革命战争，
and the American colonies, and that treaty gave American colonies ownership over all islands within 20 leagues of the American shore. That's roughly 70 miles. Machia Steel Island is less than 10 miles from the town of Cutler, Maine on the coast, and so it satisfies the conditions of this treaty. But... Yeah, there's always a button. The Treaty of Paris exempted islands that had been part of the British colony of Nova Scotia, which is now part of Canada. And the Canadians now say Machia Seal Island was included in
该条约赋予美国殖民地对美国海岸20里格（约70英里）内所有岛屿的所有权。马基亚斯海豹岛距离缅因州海岸的卡特勒镇不到10英里，因此它满足了该条约的条件。但是……是的，总有一个“但是”。《巴黎条约》豁免了那些曾是英国新斯科舍殖民地（现为加拿大的一部分）一部分的岛屿。加拿大人现在说马基亚斯海豹岛被包含在
a 1621 land grant, which deeded Nova Scotia and any island within six leagues of its coast to its British colonizers. And therefore, Machaya Seal Island belongs to Canada. However, both the Canadian and American paperwork failed to specify Machaya Seal Island by name. Well, that's a lesson for you. You have to keep your treaties tight. I get to specify everything. Just keep your, you have to keep your treaties tight. I get to specify everything. So from the late 1700s on, Macchaya Seal Island was claimed by both countries.
1621年的土地赠予中，该赠予将新斯科舍省及其海岸6里格内的任何岛屿授予其英国殖民者。因此，马基亚斯海豹岛属于加拿大。然而，加拿大和美国的文件都没有明确指出马基亚斯海豹岛的名字。嗯，这对你来说是一个教训。你必须让你的条约严密。我得明确一切。你必须让你的条约严密。我得明确一切。所以从18世纪末开始，马基亚斯海豹岛就被两国声称拥有。
Then in 1832, the British took the first step in occupying the territory by building a lighthouse there. And when Canada became a country a couple decades later, in 1867, they inherited that lighthouse. And to this day, the Canadian Coast Guard sends lighthouse keepers to live on the island, even though the lighthouse is entirely automated. Two guards operate in rotating four-week shifts, all to supposedly protect Canada's claims to sovereignty.
然后在1832年，英国通过在那里建造灯塔，迈出了占领该领土的第一步。当加拿大在几十年后的1867年成为一个国家时，他们继承了那座灯塔。直到今天，加拿大海岸警卫队仍派遣灯塔看守人住在岛上，尽管灯塔是完全自动化的。两名警卫以四周为周期轮班，所有这些据说是为了保护加拿大对主权的主张。
They don't have anything to do with the lighthouse. They mow the lawn and they help tourist land. They live on the island There's two of them, but the light functions without their intervention and when I was out there One of them told me that you know like if the light Mal functions they don't even fix it somebody else comes in and fixes it So I mean they're they're using that We talked about this in the episode called Mine. The idea of the possession of this them being present is really what it's about more than
他们与灯塔没有任何关系。他们割草并帮助游客登陆。他们住在岛上，有两个人，但灯光在没有他们干预的情况下也能运作，当我到那里时，其中一个人告诉我，你知道，如果灯光发生故障，他们甚至不修理它，别人会进来修理它。所以我的意思是，他们正在使用那个……我们在名为“我的”那一集中谈到了这一点。这种占有权，他们身处现场，这比任何事情都重要。
anything. Right. It's as if their presence earns them something like international squatters rights. The lighthouse keepers also put up warning signs and maple leaf flags throughout the island. And for decades, Canada and the US have been quietly squabbling like this over the island in these subtle ways. It sort of reminds me of like, siblings trying to share a room
对。就好像他们的存在为他们赢得了一些东西，比如国际“占屋者权利”。灯塔看守人还在岛上竖起了警告标志和枫叶旗。几十年来，加拿大和美国一直以这种微妙的方式在岛屿问题上悄悄争吵。这让我想起兄弟姐妹试图共用一个房间，
and they're just grumbling over like, you know, he touched me or, you know, like what side, what is on and how to divide it. I mean, I've been here before. Yes, exactly. And I mean, things never really escalated into dangerous conflict in regards to this island. Each country just kind of put up with the other well firmly maintaining their own position. And meanwhile, remember Barna Norton, that great grandson of Talbarni? Not only did he bring burders out to the island,
他们只是在抱怨，比如，“他碰了我”，或者，“哪一边是谁的，以及如何划分它。”我的意思是，我以前经历过这种情况。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，关于这个岛屿的事情从未真正升级为危险的冲突。每个国家只是忍受对方，同时坚定地维护自己的立场。与此同时，还记得巴纳·诺顿，那个高个子巴尼的曾孙吗？他不仅带观鸟者去岛上，
but every fourth of July for his entire adult life, Barna would sail to the island, plant American flags along the path, all the way up to the lighthouse, and ask the Canadian lighthouse keepers for rent. This is a chip off the old block. And apparently, the government of Canada sent Barna a letter every few years telling him he couldn't land on the island anymore.
而且在他成年后的每一个独立日，巴纳都会航行到岛上，沿着小路一直到灯塔插上美国国旗，并向加拿大灯塔看守人索要租金。这真是“有其父必有其子”。显然，加拿大政府每隔几年就会给巴纳发一封信，告诉他不能再登陆该岛了。
But the US State Department actually backed Barna up in 1983. They sent him a letter that said he had, quote, every right to ignore any regulation that Canada might pretend to set for Machia's seal island. And Barnock carried a copy of this letter with him when he'd visit the island to, you know, figuratively shove it in Canada's face. Anyway, eventually Barnock died in the early 80s and his claims that the island was his kind of died with him. And so did that subtle it? I mean, is the island sort of considered Canada's from that point forward? No, it did not settle it.
但美国国务院实际上在1983年支持了巴纳。他们给他发了一封信，说他有“充分的权利无视加拿大可能假装为马基亚斯海豹岛设定的任何规定”。巴纳在访问该岛时随身带着这封信的副本，你知道，形象地把它塞到加拿大的脸上。无论如何，巴纳最终在80年代初去世了，他声称该岛是他的主张也随他而去。那解决了吗？我的意思是，从那时起，该岛是否被认为是加拿大的？不，这并没有解决问题。
And actually, the dispute over this island has gotten more and more intense over the years, because it's bigger than just who gets to own this piece of rock and the birds that live on it. It's about something called the Grey Zone, which is the body of water that surrounds this island. Whoever owns the island also lays claim to these waters. And these waters happen to be the richest area for lobster fishing in the world, which means it's an area that neither country is willing to lose control over. Yeah, I guess it always comes down to money and in this case lobsters and lobsters equals money. And part of the problem of having two countries trying to claim ownership over
事实上，多年来对该岛的争端变得越来越激烈，因为它不仅仅是谁能拥有这块岩石和生活在上面的鸟类的问题。它关乎所谓的“灰色地带”，即环绕该岛的水域。谁拥有该岛，谁就对这些水域提出主张。而这些水域恰好是世界上最丰富的龙虾捕捞区，这意味着这是一个两国都不愿失去控制权的区域。是的，我想这总是归结为金钱，在这种情况下是龙虾，而龙虾等于金钱。两国试图声称对马基亚斯海豹岛和灰色地带拥有所有权的部分问题在于，两国对保护同一资源有不同的规则。所以这种情况下的资源是龙虾。两国都想确保我们不会过度捕捞，但他们使用的方法非常不同。这是斯蒂芬。例如，加拿大人，加拿大龙虾渔民不在夏季捕捞龙虾。他们让龙虾产卵和繁殖。但对于美国龙虾渔民来说，夏季是捕捞旺季。
Machaya Seal Island in the Grey Zone is that both countries have different rules for conserving the same resource. So the resource in this case is lobsters. Both countries want to make sure we don't overfish, but they're using very different means to do that. Here's Stephen again. Canadians, for example, Canadian lobster men don't fish for lobsters during the summer. They allow the lobsters to spawn and reproduce. But for American lobster men, summer is the big season.
（注：此处原文重复，已合并）
Well, Canadian fishermen complained that basically the Americans were having a free-for-all in the Grey Zone while they had to keep their boats laid up. So in 2002, lobster fishers from Canada petitioned the government to allow them to fish in the waters in and around the Grey Zone during the summer, hoping they'd get a better haul that way. So in the early 2000s, the Canadian government changed its rules to open up one fishing area in the entire eastern part of Canada to fishing during the summer, and that's the Grey Zone. They established an exception so that Canadian law enforcement could fish in the Grey Zone
嗯，加拿大渔民抱怨说，基本上美国人在灰色地带进行“自由捕捞”，而他们却不得不让船只停航。因此，在2002年，加拿大的龙虾渔民向政府请愿，允许他们在夏季在灰色地带及其周围的水域捕捞，希望这样能获得更好的渔获量。因此，在21世纪初，加拿大政府改变了规则，开放了加拿大整个东部地区的一个捕捞区，允许在夏季捕捞，那就是灰色地带。他们设立了一个例外，以便加拿大执法部门可以在灰色地带
all year long, just like the Americans do. And that's when the most recent conflicts began. Huh. So it caused more conflicts. What are we talking about here? Yeah, so this is when things start to get tense out on the water. Canadian and American lobster men threatening to cut each other's lines, stealing gear, death threats, things like that.
全年捕捞，就像美国人一样。而这就是最近冲突开始的时候。哈。所以它引起了更多的冲突。我们在这里谈论的是什么？是的，这就是水面上开始变得紧张的时候。加拿大和美国龙虾渔民威胁要切断对方的绳索、偷窃装备、发出死亡威胁等等。
One time, a 61-year-old American fisherman warned the Canadian patrol boat that he was getting ready to ram right into it. Another time, a main lobsterman got his thumb ripped off while he was trying to free his traps from Canadian fishing lines. Which brings us to today. More people from both countries are fishing in the grey zone today than ever before, and lobster prices are actually at a record high right now, which means there's more potential for conflict than ever before. Well, it sounds so intense. What are the governments doing about it? I mean, they just let him fight it out on the seas. I mean, sort of. Fantastic. The Canadians, so the Canadians are like, there's nothing to discuss here.
有一次，一位61岁的美国渔民警告加拿大巡逻艇，他准备直接撞上去。还有一次，一位缅因州的龙虾捕捞者在试图将捕虾笼从加拿大的渔网中解脱出来时，大拇指被扯断了。这让我们谈到了今天的情况。如今，在灰色地带捕鱼的两国人数比以往任何时候都多，而且龙虾价格目前处于历史高位，这意味着冲突的可能性比以往任何时候都大。听起来太紧张了。政府对此有什么作为吗？我的意思是，他们就任由他们在海上打架吗？算是吧。太棒了。加拿大人，加拿大人就像是说，这里没什么好讨论的。
Machia C. All Island in the Grey Zone belonged to us. I mean, we've had a lighthouse here since 1832. What more is there to discuss? But the legal beagles at the State Department's legal bureau say, yes, but it's been well established in cases like this. That when one country build an aid to navigation on another piece of land, that does not confer sovereignty. So in other words, they're saying that the lighthouse doesn't mean Canadians have an actual legal claim. Stephen says this kind of thing has happened a lot in land disputes between France and England,
马基亚海豹岛（Machias Seal Island）在灰色地带，属于我们。我的意思是，我们从1832年起就在这里有灯塔了。还有什么好讨论的？但国务院法律局的法律专家们说，是的，但在这种情况下已经有明确的先例。当一个国家在另一块土地上建造导航辅助设施时，这并不赋予其主权。换句话说，他们是说灯塔并不意味着加拿大人拥有实际的法律主权。斯蒂芬说，这种事情在法国和英国之间的土地争端中发生过很多次，
for example, where one of the countries built some sort of navigation marker on an island ages ago and then later claimed sovereignty over the island. And in cases like that, the World Court said, no, that's not a fair justification for ownership. You put that navigational aid there for your own purposes, and just because the other country didn't object doesn't automatically make it yours. And so the American stance is our lawyers say the lighthouse does not in and of itself prove that the Triaseal Island is Canadian.
例如，其中一个国家很久以前在岛上建造了某种导航标志，后来声称对该岛拥有主权。在这种情况下，世界法院表示，不，这不是拥有所有权的合理理由。你为了自己的目的在那里放置了导航辅助设施，仅仅因为另一个国家没有提出异议，并不自动使其成为你的。所以美国的立场是，我们的律师说灯塔本身并不能证明马基亚海豹岛是加拿大的。
So is there any way out of this impasse? I mean, likely nothing will happen, at least not from the government. You know that emoji where the person is shrugging their shoulders with their hands facing up? That's, yeah, that's kind of the direction that we're in and the direction we're heading. That's the official policy position
那么有什么办法打破这种僵局吗？我的意思是，可能什么都不会发生，至少政府不会有什么动作。你知道那个耸肩、双手向上的表情符号吗？是的，这就是我们所处的方向，也是我们正在前进的方向。这就是官方的政策立场，
of both governments is shrug emoji. Okay. And I mean, years ago, Stephen wrote an op-ed a special policy position of both governments is shrug emoji. OK. And I mean years ago, Stephen wrote an op-ed in which he proposed letting the dispute go to something called arbitration, meaning let the international court of justice look at all the legal arguments and decide whose historical claim is more valid. Both countries can make their best argument
两国政府的立场就是耸肩表情符号。好吧。我的意思是，几年前，斯蒂芬写了一篇专栏文章，他在文中提议将争端提交给所谓的仲裁，意思是让国际法院审视所有的法律论据，并决定谁的历史主张更有效。两国都可以提出他们最好的论据，
and let the court decide. Because as long as the island and the surrounding Grey Zone remains contested, it leaves open a lot of messy questions. And what happened if somebody got murdered on Macchia's seal island? So the American tour boat operator lands a bunch of Americans, they get in a dispute, one pulls out a gun and kills the other. So whose law applies? And meanwhile, there's yet another looming threat to these lobster fishers, potentially an even scarier threat than this border conflict. The waters are warming. Oh, so how does climate change like factor into this? So the waters in the Gulf of Maine have been warming up more and more each year, which
并让法院来裁决。因为只要该岛和周围的灰色地带仍然存在争议，就会留下许多棘手的问题。如果有人在马基亚海豹岛被谋杀会怎样？比如美国旅游船运营商让一群美国人上岸，他们发生了争执，一个人掏出枪杀死了另一个人。那么适用谁的法律呢？与此同时，这些龙虾捕捞者还面临着另一个迫在眉睫的威胁，可能比这种边界冲突更可怕。海水正在变暖。哦，那么气候变化是如何影响这一点的呢？缅因湾的海水每年都在变得越来越暖，这
has meant that lobstering farther down the coast, like in Massachusetts or even in southern Maine, is now becoming near impossible, because the water there is too warm for lobsters to even survive. And because the waters around Machaya Seal Island are slightly farther north, those waters are still ideal for lobsters. In fact, the waters around Machaya Seal Island have now become the epicenter for lobster production in the world. Wow. So just everything is just making this more and more of a hotspot. The gray zone is the place to be if you're a lobster fisherman totally.
意味着在海岸更南边，比如马萨诸塞州甚至缅因州南部，捕捞龙虾现在变得几乎不可能，因为那里的水温太高，龙虾甚至无法生存。由于马基亚海豹岛周围的水域稍微偏北，那里的水域仍然是龙虾的理想栖息地。事实上，马基亚海豹岛周围的水域现在已经成为世界龙虾生产的中心。哇。所以一切都让这里变得越来越热门。如果你是龙虾捕捞者，灰色地带就是必去之地，绝对是。
And the number of lobsters caught there have swored in recent years, in part because the fish that used to feed on baby lobsters, especially cod, they've been decimated. So the top level predators are gone and there's nothing to control the lobsters. So just as climate change has made the ocean off of Southern New England, inhospitibly warm for lobsters, it's warmed the waters off of Maine to a temperature that's actually more favorable to lobsters. Well, I mean, for now, I mean, presumably we could just get warmer and warmer and make it tough there too.
近年来，在那里捕获的龙虾数量激增，部分原因是过去以幼年龙虾为食的鱼类，特别是鳕鱼，已经被大量捕杀。所以顶级捕食者消失了，没有什么能控制龙虾的数量。正如气候变化使新英格兰南部海域变得对龙虾来说过于炎热一样，它也使缅因州附近的海水温度变得实际上对龙虾更有利。嗯，我的意思是，目前是这样，但推测它可能会变得越来越暖，让那里也变得困难。
Right. That's the fear. I mean, Maine's lobster catch has become so dependent on the gray zone. And you know, this lobster squabble is ultimately at the heart of why this dispute over who Macchaya seal island belongs to is still unresolved. In fact, ironically, it seems like the one thing lobster men in both countries seem to agree on is to not reach an agreement about who the water is belonged to. There's just too much at stake here for both sides, it seems, if one of them loses access
对。这就是担忧所在。我的意思是，缅因州的龙虾捕获量已经变得非常依赖灰色地带。你知道，这场龙虾争端最终是关于马基亚海豹岛归属权的争端至今未决的核心原因。事实上，具有讽刺意味的是，两国龙虾捕捞者似乎唯一能达成一致的事情就是不要就水域归属达成协议。对双方来说，如果其中一方完全失去进入这些水域的权利，代价似乎太大了。
to these waters entirely. It seems like they'd rather muddle through, you know, keeping their fingers crossed that things don't get worse. But, you know, maybe we'll eventually live in a world in which the lobsters won't exist in these waters. And then who's to say, but will we decide it about the island? Oh my goodness, Lasha. That's not the way I want this to end at all. How's that? How's that for an optimistic note to end on? Goodness. Oh no. Let's, I guess I long for a world where we're fighting over Machaya, Seal Island because then it means that it's healthy and safe.
他们似乎宁愿得过且过，你知道，祈祷事情不会变得更糟。但是，也许我们最终会生活在一个龙虾在这些水域中不存在的世界里。到时候谁说得准呢，但我们会决定岛屿的归属吗？天哪，拉莎。这根本不是我想要的结局。这怎么样？以这种乐观的基调结束怎么样？天哪。哦不。我想我渴望一个我们还在为马基亚海豹岛争斗的世界，因为那意味着它仍然健康和安全。
So, oh my God. So let's keep this feud going. Coming up, if a border falls in the woods, how do you know it's there? That story after this. So I'm back again with Kurt Colessted. You have another story about the Canadian border and you're from Minnesota. So you've had some, you've had some, you know, like actual like experience with the Canadian border a little more often than many of us on the staff except for the Canadians because
所以，天哪。所以让我们继续这场争斗吧。接下来，如果森林里有一条边界倒下了，你怎么知道它在那里？故事在广告之后。我又和库尔特·科尔斯泰德（Kurt Colessted）回来了。你有另一个关于加拿大边界的故事，你是明尼苏达人。所以你比我们大多数员工（除了加拿大人）更经常地有关于加拿大边界的实际经验，
we do have a couple of those. We have Lausanne, Cresser from Canada. But you have a lot of experience at the Canadian border as an American. You betcha. As a kid, I used to go canoeing at a YMCA summer camp called Wijewagen, which is way up in northern Minnesota, really close to Ontario. And the main base camp had this old lodge and some cabinets on the water,
因为我们确实有几个加拿大人。我们有来自加拿大的洛桑·克雷瑟（Lausanne Cresser）。但作为美国人，你在加拿大边界有很多经验。你说的没错。小时候，我经常去一个叫Wijewagen的基督教青年会夏令营划独木舟，它位于明尼苏达州北部，离安大略省非常近。主要的基地营地有一个旧旅馆和一些水上的小屋，
but that was really just a staging area. Because from there, counselors would take groups of us kids in canoes to go camping. And some of these trips were weeks long and involved crossing the border into Canada. So if you're way out in the wilderness, like how do you know that you're at the border? Well, see, I had that same question because up in the boundary waters, most of the border runs through the middle of lakes. So there are no road signs.
但这实际上只是一个集结区。因为从那里开始，辅导员会带着我们这些孩子分组划独木舟去露营。其中一些旅行长达数周，涉及越过边界进入加拿大。所以如果你在荒野深处，你怎么知道你在边界上呢？嗯，看，我有同样的问题，因为在边界水域，大部分边界穿过湖泊的中间。所以没有路标。
There's no like border crossing station. And my first year out our camp counselors pulled up a map in the middle of a lake and then had us campers squint into the water. They told us to look for a red and white Canadian colored border chain at the bottom of the lake below. Well, like a giant metal chain under the water,
没有像边境检查站那样的东西。我第一年出去的时候，我们的营地辅导员在湖中央拿出了一张地图，然后让我们这些露营者眯着眼睛看水里。他们告诉我们寻找水底下一条红白相间的加拿大颜色边界链。就像水底下一条巨大的金属链，
like painted like the Canadian flag. And you know, being kids, some of us believed it, at least at first, of course they were pulling our chain, so to speak. So sorry. I'm so sorry. I mean, that would have fooled me. If you told me it happened now, I would look, wow, that's amazing. You have to stop and think about it.
涂得像加拿大国旗一样。你知道，作为孩子，我们中的一些人相信了，至少起初是这样，当然他们是在开我们的玩笑。抱歉。我太抱歉了。我的意思是，那也会骗到我。如果你告诉我它现在发生了，我会看，哇，那太神奇了。你必须停下来思考一下。
And if you think about it, it does seem crazy to try to mark out this whole border at all, right? Because it's thousands of miles long and, you know, literally the longest international border in the world. And it runs over lakes and forests and mountains. So you have to wonder like, how would anybody mark a boundary like that?
如果你仔细想想，试图标记整个边界确实看起来很疯狂，对吧？因为它有数千英里长，而且确实是世界上最长的国际边界。它穿过湖泊、森林和山脉。所以你不得不怀疑，怎么会有人标记那样的边界呢？
But then more recently, I read about the slash. Oh, so what is the slash? I mean, that sounds pretty ominous. Yeah, it does. But it's this clear cut area that extends 10 feet on either side of the border. And when I first found out about it, it really did sound like another, like,
但后来我最近读到了关于“斜线”（the slash）的内容。哦，那么什么是斜线？听起来很不祥。是的，确实。但这是一个在边界两侧延伸10英尺的清理区域。当我第一次发现它时，它听起来确实像另一个，
maybe this is a myth thing that came called the slurs, you know, tell gullible kids. Because it's pretty uncanny. Like, if you look at an aerial view, particularly in a rural area with lots of trees, it looks like some God just took an exacto knife and sliced a straight line through the forest. It's like unnatural.
也许这是一个用来骗轻信孩子的神话。因为它非常不可思议。就像，如果你看鸟瞰图，特别是在有很多树的农村地区，看起来就像上帝拿了一把美工刀在森林里切出了一条直线。它看起来很不自然。
That actually does sound like something Kim Consul should make up because it sounds like a surprisingly difficult task. Yeah, absolutely. It's this really strange, almost unbelievable, gigantic epic project. And we're talking about a huge coast to coast border. And a lot of it's in really remote,
那听起来确实像是金·康苏尔（Kim Consul）会编造的东西，因为它听起来是一项令人惊讶的艰巨任务。是的，绝对是。这是一个非常奇怪、几乎令人难以置信的巨大史诗工程。我们谈论的是一个巨大的横跨海岸的边界。而且其中很多是在非常偏远、
harder-reach areas, too. Well, it sounds like a lot of work, especially when, to really appreciate it, you kind of have to look at a satellite photo, you know? Which, yeah, it's like you don't really like do things geared towards satellites. Yeah, most people at the border, you know, like they don't see this, right? Like it's not like a tourist attraction, but it is a ton of work except it's less work than other approaches would be. So for context, like the rules around international board specify that they have to be really clear to have legal weight
难以到达的地区。嗯，听起来工作量很大，特别是当你真正欣赏它时，你必须看卫星照片，你知道吗？这就像你不会真的做针对卫星的事情。是的，边界上的大多数人，你知道，他们看不到这个，对吧？它不像是一个旅游景点，但它确实需要大量的工作，只是比其他方法的工作量要少。为了背景说明，国际边界周围的规则规定它们必须非常清晰才能具有法律效力，
And a wall would be like a huge pain, right? And it would disrupt wildlife So it turns out that nothingness this intentional absence of a physical barrier It's actually in this case a pretty clever and simple design solution But presumably I mean to keep it nothing. I mean like nature takes things over when you do not pay attention to it. So what keeps the trees from coming back in? Are they constantly working? Well, sort of. They let it grow out a little bit, but they have these groups. There's this International Boundary Commission, which is a joint venture between the US and Canada. Each country sends their own crews and equipment
而一堵墙会非常麻烦，对吧？而且它会破坏野生动物。所以事实证明，虚无，这种故意的物理屏障缺失，在这种情况下实际上是一个非常聪明和简单的设计方案。但推测，我的意思是，要保持这种虚无。我的意思是，当你注意不到它时，大自然会接管一切。那么是什么阻止了树木长回来呢？他们一直在工作吗？嗯，算是吧。他们让它长一点，但他们有这些小组。有一个国际边界委员会，这是美国和加拿大之间的合资企业。每个国家都派遣自己的工作人员和设备，
to maintain like different parts of the slash at different times. And both sides coordinate periodically, they meet up and divvy up the work so that none of it gets too tall. And like there's always somebody like watching the different parts. So this is a roving group of landscapers.
在不同时间维护斜线的不同部分。双方定期协调，他们会面并分配工作，这样就不会有任何地方长得太高。而且总是有人在监视不同的部分。所以这是一群流动的园丁。
There's a hike and a round, they're cutting down trees that are like clearing brush. Yeah, that's it, no, not chill. And some of them in the east can at least stay at hotels, but those in the west and other places like have to camp in more rural areas. And as you might imagine, this gig can be really hard. It involves really remote places and rough terrain.
他们四处走动，砍伐树木，清理灌木丛。是的，就是这样，不，不轻松。其中一些在东部的人至少可以住在酒店，但那些在西部和其他地方的人必须在更偏远的地区露营。正如你可能想象的那样，这份工作可能非常艰苦。它涉及非常偏远的地方和崎岖的地形。
And a lot of their work is just getting to and from the slash. Yeah. And like, I can see why the slash works. Again, like we said, like from, like, looking at it from a great height, in terms of satellites, you can sort of mark the border. But like, why not just put it a plaque in every? You don't like every, I don't know, 100 yards maybe,
而且他们很多工作只是往返于斜线之间。是的。而且，我能看出为什么斜线有效。再说一次，就像我们说的，从高处看，就卫星而言，你可以标记边界。但为什么不每隔，我不知道，也许100码放一块牌子呢？
it seems like that would be easier than clearing a bunch of trees. Well, they sort of do that too. There are these little monuments along the border, but it's really the slash that makes the crossing clear because if you imagine like the border only having markers or signs or plaques, they would have to be huge and really tightly spaced to be visible
那似乎比清理一堆树要容易。嗯，他们也这样做。边界沿线有这些小纪念碑，但真正让过境点清晰的是斜线，因为如果你想象边界只有标记、标志或牌子，它们必须非常巨大且非常紧密地排列才能在农村地区的所有树木中可见。
amidst like all the trees in a rural area. But in clear cut zones, they would have to be huge and really tightly spaced to be visible amidst like all the trees in a rural area. But in clear cut zones, they can be much smaller and you can see them. And so that visibility created by the slash helps reduce the odds of someone accidentally whining up on the wrong side, like a jogger innocently crossing without even realizing what they're doing. Yeah. So if you're jogging through this remote part of the forest or whatever it is, I don't
但在清理区域，它们可以小得多，你可以看到它们。因此，斜线创造的这种可见性有助于减少某人意外走到错误一侧的几率，比如一个慢跑者在甚至没有意识到自己在做什么的情况下无意中越过了边界。是的。所以如果你在森林的这个偏远部分慢跑，或者无论它是什么，我不知道你如何到达大多数这些地方。但如果你在那里徒步穿越森林，遇到这种不自然的线性清理区，这是一个很好的迹象，表明你已经到达了边界，你应该回头。
know how you would probably reach most of these places. But if you were hiking through the forest there and you came across this like unnaturally linear clearing, it's a good sign that you hit the border and you should turn back. Yeah, exactly. And when I think about it and I compared this project to that fictitious border chain we were talking about, and how much work that would take to do, I really can't help but think it sounds even more believable like in hindsight, right?
是的，完全正确。当我想到这一点，并将这个项目与我们谈论的那个虚构的边界链进行比较，以及完成它需要多少工作时，我真的不禁认为事后看来它听起来更可信，对吧？
Like if they can do this slash, they could do a border chain, too. Oh, for sure. I think they could do it more easily. Just like, just like, links of chains across the border. Just plain sense to find. Oh my goodness. Well, just like, links of change across. It's totally makes sense to find. Oh my goodness.
就像如果他们能做这个斜线，他们也能做边界链。哦，当然。我认为他们可以更容易地做到。就像，就像，横跨边界的链条链接。完全有道理。天哪。好吧，就像，横跨边界的链条链接。完全有道理。天哪。
Well, that is really fascinating. Well, there's some news you can use if you're a remote hiker. You know when you cross the border. So we're here to keep you out of trouble. Yeah. And if you really like nerding out about specifically the border between Minnesota and Canada,
好吧，那真的很迷人。好吧，如果你是一个偏远地区的徒步旅行者，这里有一些你可以使用的消息。你知道什么时候越过边界。所以我们在这里是为了让你远离麻烦。是的。如果你真的喜欢钻研明尼苏达州和加拿大之间的边界，
you can check out an episode where Roman and I talked about the Northwest Angle, which is another really fascinating aspect of a border that you've probably never thought about before and may never think about again. Yeah, it's this little chunk of Minnesota that sort of is separated by the lake and is connected to Canada, which is really, that's a weird place. It's a very weird place. That's great. Thank you, Kurt. 99% invisible was produced this week by Kurt Colestead, Vivian Leigh, and La Shima Don, mixed in tech production by Amida Kanatra, music by a director of sound, Swanria.
你可以查看一集我和罗曼（Roman）谈论西北角（Northwest Angle）的节目，这是你以前可能从未想过，以后可能再也不会想到的边界的另一个非常迷人的方面。是的，这是明尼苏达州的一小块，被湖泊隔开并与加拿大相连，这真的很奇怪，那是一个奇怪的地方。这是一个非常奇怪的地方。太棒了。谢谢你，库尔特。《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）本周由库尔特·科尔斯泰德、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）和拉希玛·唐（La Shima Don）制作，混音和技术制作由阿米达·卡纳特拉（Amida Kanatra）完成，音乐由声音总监斯旺里亚（Swanria）负责。
Delaney Hall is the executive producer, the rest of the team includes Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and a show at 99PI org. On Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other stature shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pi.org. S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S-S- There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是执行制片人，团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）和我罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们是Stitcher & Sirius XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。在Instagram和Reddit上也可以。你可以在99pi.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及99PI的每一集往期节目。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。